For the last 48 years.
Dr. Joyce Poole has been eavesdropping
on elephant families,
learning their language.
I speak to elephants.
I rumbled to them if they seem upset.
I say hello and things.
Their vocabulary is very large.
Elephants have over 30 vocalizations.
Their rumbles the low frequency calls.
Their roars, their trumpet,
their cries.
Wants to suckle.
Yeah. Oh.
So that's when it escalates.
That's when the suckle rumble didn't work.
And then you have to escalate.
So saying, Mum, put your leg forward.
Mom is not being very co-operative.
There's an ally, mother.
Just like a baby sitter.
She doesn't have any milk, but
she can comfort the baby.
Females from the age about three,
four years old
will try and take care of babies.
That was called a Bruv Rumble.
It’s a kind of (roar)
like, oh, poor me.
And the ally mother responded with a reassuring
cou rumble
Okay,
that's lovely.
See how reaching back there
she's trying to show the baby
where to suckle.
So even though the ally mother
is not able to produce milk like mum does,
she does provide comfort
and that forms a close bond.
Still making that little sound that's like
I want it's a it's a sucker rumble.
But it's a more complaining one.
Obviously, it's not getting any milk.
Okay.
Now it's going to mum
to get some real milk
suckle rumble
that she puts her leg forward
to let the calf suckle.
Very cute.
After decades
decoding the calls of savanna
elephants, Joyce has discovered a language
more elaborate than we ever imagined.
Elephants
do combine different types of calls.
They can combine and make a rumble,
roar, rumble,
roar, rumble or a rumble trumpet.
A snort trumpet.
What we don't know is whether by combining
those two different types,
they're making it, in a sense, a new word.
Elephant conversations
can be incredibly complex.
All of their rumbles
contain infrasonic components
that is below the level of human hearing.
And elephants can hear
these powerful rumbles from miles away
and also pick them up
as vibrations
through their feet and trunk.
Sometimes they can back and forth
for up to an hour,
literally having a kind of conversation
or having a discussion about something.
It's very obvious.
It's not just noise.
It has meaning
they’re So like us,
they communicate
about some of the same things that we do.
And this communication is part of the glue
that holds the whole family together.